By rejecting the null, we know that at least two of the foods differ in terms
of mean amount consumed. But we don't know which ones differ. We can see that
all three of the means differ from each other, but we don't know if these
differences are due to sampling error. Therefore, we need to do additional
testing to see which means are different. This additional testing is called
multiple comparison test. So we're able to compare all of the means with each
other. We wouldn't do a multiple comparison test until after we've done ANOVA.
One of the most common multiple comparison tests is called Tukey's HSD, which
stands for Honestly Significant Difference It's named after John Tukey, a very
influential statistician. Tukey's HSD evaluates the significance of the
difference between any two group means. In statistics, we say that this test
will allow us to make pairwise comparisons. The way we calculate Tukey's HSD is
just like the margin of error that you've learned before. Remember that with
the z test, it was the z critical value, denoted z star times the standard
error. And remember with the t test, it was the t critical value times the
standard error. But now when we're comparing three or more samples, we have a
new statistic called Q. And we multiply this by this square root of the mean
square for within subject varibility divided by n. You might ask how is this
similar to these. Well, the mean square for within subject variability is the
pooled variance. It's just the average square deviation of each value from its
respective group mean. Therefore, the square root is the pooled standard
deviation. Q is the student highest range statistic, and we find this in yet
another table. It's purpose is to adjust the whole HSD, so that it's less
likely we commit a type one error. Remember a type one error is when we reject
the null hypothesis when it's actually true since q increases when there are
more groups that we're comparing, it makes it less likely to commit a type one
error. Remember that if a sample mean was further away from the population
mean, than the margin of error, it was considered unlikely. Well if two sample
means are further apart than the Tukey's HSD then that's considered honestly,
significantly different.